[Music]
presents are a serious thing but parents
with a sense of humor will love these
toys from knockoffs to cleverly fixed
toys these are the presents to give when
you want to pull a prank on your kids
stay tuned to hear about the ultimate
trol toy that made its creator a
millionaire give this video a thumbs up
and hit that subscribe button to never
miss another video again now let's check
out 20 toys parents should buy to troll
their kids 100 things from the dollar
store let's start with one of the
greatest trolling presents we have ever
seen the dollar store is fun but what
would happen if you told your child you
purchased a gift that was worth $100 and
it turned out to be 100 items from the
dollar store we have a feeling there
would be a few that would go into a
complete meltdown of course not all of
these are probably toys but the idea
behind it is pretty clever we appreciate
the time it took for each present to get
individually wrapped so beautifully and
with a different wrapping paper
stay tuned for some of the best troll
toys ever drippy the runny nose kids all
got a kid with a constant runny nose
this is one of the weirdest toys ever
but we bet a lot of parents would have a
good laugh with this one it's called
drippy known as the runny nose kid we're
honestly not sure what's the point of
this vintage doll but the dolls hands
look like it can't help it's drippy nose
a perfect gifts for the kid that always
manages to catch a cold
you can also put goo inside the doll's
nose and when you press the stomach
it'll come out sure it's vintage but you
have to admit it would be entertaining
to see a New Age kid play with this
American man action figure This American
Man toy is an athlete sportsman and a
trooper of course there's no official
American man hero out there but this is
the best troll toy for those who are
constantly asking for new action figures
this toy also claims it has magical
outfits and uniforms that are extremely
easy to press on and that's pretty much
all that is to this Action Man that's
supposed to be a huge athlete
unfortunately we'll never find out how
good he is at sports since no kind of
access
come with this so-called action figure
what a letdown milky the marvelous
milking cow got a child who's a city
slicker get them to experience just a
little bit of farm life with this
marvelous milking cow the toy comes with
actual utters and a pretend milk
you can also pump or tell to make her
drink water and do all sorts of things
usual cows do on a farm the advertising
for the cow made it clear that the toy
was using totally pretend milk although
we don't see how that would make any
difference in the fact that this is one
of the oddest toys we have ever seen
we'll definitely pass on the marvelous
milking cow but if you want to troll
your kids then this is the best present
ever
the in face of bulls is your child
obsessed with action figures like
transformers ninja turtles or even
Spider Man bring them all together with
this vintage 80s toy collection called
the in face Able's they are known as the
mystic warriors of change and unlike
your kids favorite figures they aren't
inspired by someone from TV although
we're sure that will be a letdown for a
lot of kids
the invasive bulls are actually a pretty
amazing collection of vintage toys but
we have a feeling vintage won't really
impress kids who are all about their
favorite action figures nevertheless
this is an excellent troll toy to teach
kids about parents childhood toys daddy
saddle we have a feeling this when we
get old very quickly and we actually
can't believe that this was a toy the
daddy saddle is made for those who like
to carry their kids on their backs
although we're sure a lot of kids would
actually enjoy this present this is a
perfect way for the wife to make sure
the kids get off her back for a few
minutes and hop on her husband's this
strange toy has also been crowned as one
of the weirdest ever but we have a
feeling it would make a perfect revenge
toy to make sure moms have a couple of
minutes to themselves while the child
plays an upgraded game of horse e EO
ball v physical acts Bo ball is a
strange toy that connects technology
with physical activities it was also
crowned as one of the worst toys of 2012
and we can definitely see why it's a
ball that holds a very
piece of technology we have a feeling
this one that only trolls kids but also
their parents
can you imagine letting a child
carelessly bounce a ball like that with
an iphone stuck inside on the other side
we have no idea how a child would even
be able to interact with the phone and
hold the ball at the same time this is
definitely a recipe for disaster
puto here's another troll toy that would
probably traumatize any child who's not
a huge fan of the poo emoji the puto is
basically play-doh that looks like
something that came out of a child's
behind to make things even better the
parents can make this beforehand and
just wrap the dough as is imagine the
child's space as they unwrap the present
and reveal it's actually just food oh
you can also upgrade this prank by
putting on a smelly spray to make it
look even more believable this is a
perfect way to mess around with spoiled
kids who normally get everything they
want James Bond double O 5 the best way
to troll your kids is with knockoff toys
a parent with a sense of humor will have
a blast watching their child through a
tantrum as they've realized they've been
practically ripped off like with this
knockoff for example as you might know
James Bond is a double-oh-seven agent
but that's not apparently true
everywhere check out this secret agent
double-oh v that's ready to fight the
bad guys if you have a child that
obsessively looks up to the mysterious
secret agents trolling them with this
knockoff toy would be hilarious of
course don't forget to give them the
real deal after transformable Thomas
let's check out some more knockoff toys
that are just too funny and obvious to
ignore we all know Thomas the Tank
Engine this show was a part of a lot of
our childhoods but we have no idea what
this knockoff is supposed to represent
if you have a kid that loves the
Transformers troll them with this
hilarious knockoff it's transformable
Thomas advertised as a Super Robot this
toy is definitely not the official look
of Thomas the Tank Engine but we have to
admit it's still pretty impressive we
have
feeling kids won't say the same though
which is why this would be the most
perfect troll toy Bland's in this girl
classic Disney Princesses are often
criticized for their bland personality
and this knockoff says it like it is if
you have a Disney obsessed kid this
might be the perfect toy to troll them
with and share your sentiments on Disney
Princesses this knockoff is called the
blandness girl and it comes with a super
old-school mobile phone toy most kids
won't even know how to use it's funny
how you can totally tell they're meant
to be Disney Princesses and all they've
changed is their name even the font
still resembles Disney a perfect
trolling gift for those whose Disney and
Technology obsession is going a bit out
of control
the question is with the kids even
notice this isn't the real thing we
don't even know what to call this we
have a feeling The Simpsons and the
Pokemon fans would take a lot of offense
to this saw it's definitely not a toy
but it's such a brilliant trolling gift
we thought we'd add it to our list we
have no idea what to call it but we bet
diehard fans of both shows would have a
thing or two to say about this strange
character is it Homer Simpson or is it
Pikachu these two might be both yellow
but that doesn't mean you should merge
them together do you think your child
would believe that this is a new breed
of Pokemon that's totally unique and
never seen before
III Theo move over c-3po there's a new
toy in town or should we say a knockoff
toy that stole si fukiyose name and et's
look if you have a Star Wars fan in your
house this is an amazing trolling gift
nobody really wants to receive this tiny
toy is supposed to represent a c3
yo but we have a feeling the toy makers
missed the memo that the intelligent
robot looks absolutely nothing like et
give this to someone who you know will
absolutely rage over the fact that you
thought this looks anything like c-3po
it's not just kids we bet there are
diehard Star Wars fans out there that
will take full of Finn's to this
knockoff booth chasers ghostbusters
aren't saying of the Pats for this
knockoff toy that's basically the same
thing with a different name we bet most
kids won't even realize that are holding
a cheap imitation that's nowhere nearly
close to the actual ghostbusters this
spook chasers toy comes with a single
figurine a weird ghost slime and a
gadget that apparently resembles the
ghostbusters equipment we're not
entirely sure how this one works so we
have a feeling this one might be a total
letdown for kids who expect it to get an
amazing ghost busting piece of
technology Hannah Montana it's the best
of both worlds with this Hannah Montana
knockoff toy it looks like Hannah
Montana
it has Hannah Montana's font but
Hannah's name seems to be Anna according
to this knockoff according to the
packaging this toy sings Hannah
Montana's theme song best of both worlds
and does everything the actual popstar
does do you think the kids would even
notice they're holding a complete
knockoff
that's actually named Anna Montana
without the letters H it's definitely a
toy to troll Miley Cyrus fans with
although you might want to make sure you
have a back-up plan in case you'll have
to witness a real meltdown dark Raeder
Batman but while Hannah Montana might no
longer be a popular show Batman is still
a popular character and an idol to many
young kids so imagine what would happen
if someone would actually get a toy like
this one the dark rehder Batman is a
knockoff toy that's basically spider-man
gone wrong we all know kids love having
debates over which one's better Batman
or spider-man we have a feeling this toy
would leave a lot of them offended
confused at the same time get ready
because you might have to wipe away a
lot of tears after giving out this
heartbreaking toy little animal
telephone every child wants the latest
piece of technology whether it's a
laptop a new gaming system or a phone
even though some of them are definitely
too young to use them troll your kids
with this Teletubbies knockoff toy that
plays music with every push of a button
it looks like a real deal until you see
the toys name Teletubbies have been
changed to little animals even though we
all know these strange creatures are
definitely not animals speaking of
strange check out ditzies eyes he
definitely doesn't look like he's
feeling well we have a feeling most kids
but want to stay away from the little
animal telephone phone kitty speaking of
Technology one of the best ways to troll
your kid is to hand them a toy phone to
remind them what they should actually be
playing with at their age but this toy
isn't from the popular Hello Kitty brand
it's called foam kitty and you actually
get two phones inside imagine telling
your child they'll be getting the new
phone and they end up with this the
green phone to the left is a music phone
while the right is an imitation of a
mobile phone and the best part is they
only cost $4 according to the price tag
talk about a true bargain politic Pat's
tie magnets sound cool but we're not
really sure how we feel about that if
you really want to insult someone and
start a debate you will with this
knockoff that's just absolutely
hilarious
Pokemon whoo it's all about politics Pat
they look like Pokemon but they're
actually magnetic toys there's Pikachu
and a bunch of other characters you can
easily find in a poke Tex but they're
called politic Pat instead you have no
idea what these toys have to do with
politics at all but we bet any Pokemon
fan would get offended by these magnets
get ready because this troll toy is
definitely going to start a few
arguments pet rocks but out of all troll
toys out there there's only one that's
the king
them all its pet rocks if your child's
constantly asking you to get a dog or a
cat but you know they're not ready for
that responsibility
you can test their skills with pet rocks
it's strange to think that the creator
of pet rocks is actually a millionaire
when he basically sold rocks as pets
many modern kids might not remember pet
rocks at all and we can imagine a lot of
them would end up in tears after opening
up their presents we still think this is
one of the best troll toys out there and
that's it for our video for more videos
like this one check out ten toys that
weren't supposed to be for kids see you
next time
[Music]